unsere galaxie die milchstraße hat nicht
nur unvorstellbare zahlen zu bieten sie
beherbergt wohl 100 milliarden sterne
und erstreckt sich über unfassbare 120
tausend lichtjahre unsere galaxie ist
auch gewaltiger und heller als die
meisten anderen um sie herum liegen eine
hülle aus wasserstoffgas das zeigen der
teleskope und zudem wird sie von vielen
kleineren galaxien um schüler die alten
griechen dachten die glötter hätten
milch verschüttet als sie das mädchen
schelle band am himmel entdeckten und so
kamen sie zu ihrem namen galaxis das
griechische wort für mich hier die fünf
spannendsten und spektakulärsten fakten
über die milchstraße unserer galaxie
klicks um science-fiction hier gibt es
täglich faszinieren des seins videos
abonniert den kanal nur dann verpasste
nichts herzlich willkommen vielen lieben
dank für diesen tollen themenvorschlag
aus der whatsapp community effect 1 so
ist sie milchstraße entstanden
dafür war die schwerkraft die
gravitation hauptverantwortlich die
milchstraße entstand wohl aus
gigantischen gaswolken aus der frühzeit
des universums diese waren aus dem
gleichgewicht geraten und durch ihre
eigene gravitation in sich
zusammengefallen dabei drehte sich die
gaswolke immer schneller denn je näher
die masse an der rotationsachse ist umso
schneller dreht sie sich quasi wie bei
einer eiskunstläuferin die die arme an
den körper angelegt hat die schnelle
rotation sorgte für größere fliehkräfte
was dazu führte dass die wolke abflachte
so hat die milchstraße die form einer
flachen scheibe erhalten zweiter effekt
die milchstraße auf der waage so schwer
ist sie es seit juni 2018 wissen wir wie
viel unsere milchstraße eigentlich liegt
schätzungen zufolge liegt ihre
gesamtmasse bei 960 milliarden
sonnenmassen eingerechnet sind die
sichtbare und unsichtbare dunkle materie
dunkle materie machten im jetzigen stand
der astrophysik rund 85 prozent der
materie des universums auf dieses
ergebnis zu kommen war gar nicht mal so
einfach denn unser sonnensystem hat eine
besondere lage um die milchstraße zu
vermessen müssten wir eigentlich von
außen auf sich schauen können doch das
ist alles andere als einfach denn unser
sonnensystem befindet sich
innerhalb der galaktischen scheibe doch
ein forschungsteam aus arizona hatte
eine andere idee um die milchstraße zu
wiegen dazu analysierten die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
bekannte satellitengalaxien wie sie die
milchstraße auf epileptischen bahnen
umkreisen
vor allem ging es ihnen um den
drehimpuls der satellitengalaxien durch
computersimulationen gelang es ihnen so
den einfluss der milchstraße auf die
kleinen trabanten zu bestimmen so kamen
sie dann auch an die gesamtmasse der
galaxis dieses verfahren könnte auch zum
wiegen anderer großer stern systeme
taugen so die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler auch wenn diese
schätzung eine unsicherheit von gut 240
milliarden sonnenmassen enthält ist das
immer noch weniger als in früheren
studien zu diesem thema dritte effekt
dass massemonster im zentrum der
milchstraße der schnellste stern in der
zentralregion der galaxis rus mit 5000
kilometern pro sekunde um die mitte der
galaxie
dafür braucht er nur 15 jahre um sie
einmal zu umrunden teams aus astronomen
und astronomen rechneten nach wie groß
die kräfte sein müssen
die solche zentrumsnahen sterne auf
ihrem engen kurven bahn halten und so
stand schnell fest in der mitte der
milchstraße muss ich einen massemonster
befinden dass eine millionenfach größere
masse als die sonne hat bau und diese
masse ist auf engstem raum zusammen
gepackt ein schwarzes loch also sein
name sagittarius aussterben
forschungsteams vermuten dass es in
unserer galaxie millionen solcher
schwarzer löcher geben könnte japanische
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
hatten erst 2016 ein weiteres schwarzes
loch entdeckt dass hunderttausend mal
massereicher als unsere sonne ist das
forschungsteam vermutet dass es
irgendwann einmal die größe eines
supermassiven schwarzen lochs erreicht
für perfekt heiße gase um die
milchstraße herum seit 2010 wissen wir
so genannte fermi blasen also
gigantische blasen reiser gase und
energiegeladener teilchen werden vom
galaktischen zentrum ausgestoßen wie
genau sie entstehen ist noch nicht ganz
geklärt eine vermutung der
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
ist aber dass sie mit den vielen sternen
im zusammenhang stehen die im umkreis
von sagittarius stern dem
supermassereichen schwarzen loch im
zentrum der milchstraße entstehen und
auch zerstört werden
mit hilfe des green bank teleskop hatte
ein forschungsteam beobachtet
die rund 100 wasserstoff wolken richtung
rand der galaxie rasen dahinter stecken
nach vermutung des forschungsteams wohl
die prozesse die auch die fermi blasen
erzeugend fünfter fängt auch die
milchstraße wird irgendwann einmal
sterben forschungsteams glauben dass die
milchstraße nicht ewig existieren würden
etwa vier milliarden jahren wird sie
nämlich mitte andromeda-galaxie ihrem
nachbarn zusammengestoßen gerade kommen
sie sich immer näher und das nicht zu
knapp mit etwa 400.000 kilometer pro
stunde trafen sie aufeinander zu doch
die folgen von dem zusammenprall werden
vielleicht gar nicht so fatal sein wie
man zunächst denken würde nach ansicht
vieler wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler würde die erde
beispielsweise diese kollisionen
überleben einige sterne dagegen nicht
entstehen würde dann wohl eine mega
galaxie die um sowohl neue als auch
altbekannte sterne beerbt hier
draufklicken entfernte galaxie
hochauflösender blick an den rand des
universums cooles video unbedingt
anschauen und natürlich neugier zone
abonnieren bis dann bleibt dran